while many film and tv productions
remain on hold because of copen 19 kiana
reeves i
love keanu reeves and the matrix
forecast has been back in berlin since
last
june shooting the new installment in the
franchise and keanu says
it's going well you know i think
everyone
you know loves the project and
uh just really i mean if you're ever
gonna get into any kind of
situation that needs to be figured out
or how do we do this
show business people are the best you
know we just
we're scrappy we know how to get stuff
done we're inventive
we think on our feet um
and you know that kind of spirit kindred
spirit of just coming together you know
it goes back to like
you know let's put on a show you know
we'll get some props we've got some
things we're gonna write you know and
and that
and that spirit is definitely alive and
well
on the matrix um from a filmmaking
standpoint
um it's well it's it's great and an
honor i'm very grateful
to be to be working um
i'm here in berlin with the sirens but
uh you know the um
you know there's some really uh
thoughtful
effective protocols in place and the
rhythm of filmmaking has been
um not really impacted or interrupted
in the sense of filming but that's
because of this all the hard work and
and organization and again
thoughtfulness that's gone into the
protocols
that's something like my apartment
downtown toronto there's always sirens
going by typically
it's usually my apartment yeah i'm
shocked that they've been back since
late june
during this germany's handle this like
like where uh sharon stone said
i mean germany's led by angela merkel
and they've handled it very well but i'm
still surprised they were back
that early i gotta tell you i'm uh
optimistic about this oh sorry you go
ahead no go ahead go no you go ahead go
ahead
well i just like i i'm a big fan
of blockbusters and like i was just
thinking ahead to next year being like
i don't know what's gonna happen with
blockbuster season you know 2021 because
if there are no films being shot this
year there won't be that many being
released next year and what am i going
to do
but mercifully some films are back under
like a lot of uh like really strict
guidelines i think
uh jurassic park talked about this uh
earlier in the year as well
um so there will be something to look
forward to if theaters are like open
again
hopefully that's what i'm that's what
i'm hoping for so i just like
i'm all for this please entertain me in
a year because i'm desperately gonna
need it
yeah it's so interesting you say that
because we don't know what's gonna
happen with phil's i mean i was supposed
to be
with tom cruise revision impossible last
month did it happen
uh you know like it's all what movies
are still being played and you're right
the whole cinema experience is that
going to be in place as well and we have
a drive-in
uh not far from us and it's so wonderful
to go out there and see the films but
it's not the same experience
it's very different um but you know the
fact that he's creating a movie matrix
for i can't wait for it but
you're right like what does the future
hold for for production and
one of the great things if you watch i
don't know if you guys watch soap operas
but young and the restless is back in
making production
of their shows and they're doing all of
their shots social distance so when they
do those things you know the love scenes
they actually do with their partners so
they're getting creative right there's
ways
you can actually make television yeah so
the partner has to be the kissing scene
so
it works it can happen that's great wait
like yeah and grey's anatomy and after
they're back too but yeah this other
show's like this is us that yeah don't
know when they're going to be back like
we had brandon on on um
brandon mcknight on friday the flash
they don't know when they're going to be
back
but yeah so i've seen berlin like things
are a bit different and yeah it is
it is becoming a bit strange that yeah
the dude it's becoming a have and have
not situation that
if you have the money you can have the
proper testing because obviously the
maker has been at it for
let's say six weeks now they haven't had
any outbreak on set so they're obviously
doing the proper testing
so why can't that be in you know given
to the public that level of
testing in in canada in the u.s so
that's what gets a little bit scary that
it's starting to be like yeah the haves
are able to get back to work and do
things properly and stay safe but the
have-nots can't so that's a little bit
scary and yeah the other thing too i
mean what i was thinking yeah they're
getting back to shooting these movies
but there's a huge backlog of all these
movies that are done
that didn't release since like march so
like that i know mulan's now going to be
on disney plus but all the other ones
yeah like top gun uh like all these
movies they're all done they've
got a quiet place too like they've all
been ready so yeah it's funny that
they're going out and shooting these
more movies when like you got this whole
backlog of movies that
you said we have no idea when theaters
are going to actually properly reopen
but all that means is like more for me
next summer you know like
i'm ready i'm ready for for like the
fast and the furious maybe we'll shoot
two
two together i don't know what's going
on because i was supposed to come out in
april um you got james bonding up got
pushed in november
i'm not like my i'm spiritually ready
you know i'm just
ready for like a glut of films like if
you release 50 of them i'm like i'll be
there for every one of them
but every day yeah every day why not but
having said that like
it's a waiting game it's a waiting game
to see like what theaters are going to
do i saw that
cineplex is inviting people back for
like you know i think they have like
five dollar ticket or something like
that
um like that's an inventive way to get
people through the door because they're
allowed to be open now but
there are no new movies being released
yet so it's like a
it's a continuously wait-and-see kind of
situation
yeah i'm really like tennessee you enjoy
watching movies oh
yeah like tenants will see a big one
that's supposed to come out in in two
weeks yeah we'll see if that
still happens and yeah where it opens
but yeah that tenants must be the one
that kind of brings people back to
theaters so we'll see in a couple weeks
i'm desperate i thought it was spongebob
that's supposed to bring everyone back
isn't he releasing the movie right now
that's fast
pop squarepants the big one big release
true
the big
can't wait to get into that pineapple
under the sea let's go
spongebob versus tennis that's the real
showdown at this that's right